let T of T denote the temperature
capital T in New York City measured in
Celsius degrees or degrees Celsius when
it's T lowercase T hours after midnight
on a given day the function is graphed
below the following table contains true
statements match each statement with the
feature on the graph that most core most
closely corresponds to it so once again
this is capital T as a function of
lowercase T's temperature as a function
of time so we see at time equals 0 the
temperature is negative 3 degrees
Celsius and then as we go to 8 hours
later the temperature is at zero degrees
Celsius and then it hits a it hits at
least a relative maximum point or at
least from what we see it could even be
a global Maxima but but based on what we
see it's definitely a relative maximum
point 14 hours into into this
measurement at time equals 14 and then
the temperature starts to go down again
so let's see so advertises T hours after
midnight so this is this is at midnight
this is going to be at 8:00 a.m. this is
going to be at noon and this is going to
be at 2:00 p.m. and so on and so forth
but anyway the feature y-intercept so
the y-intercept is right over here and
we see when lowercase T when time is 0 0
hours after midnight the temperature in
New York City is negative 3 degrees
Celsius so it was negative 3 degrees
Celsius at the beginning of the day yeah
that's a true statement and especially
if you consider the beginning of the day
the true beginning of the day is right
at midnight so that's that one the
y-intercept tells us this true statement
so positive or negative interval and
these questions are a little bit tricky
because you don't have to use it's the
positive or the negative interval it
doesn't have to be both so if either the
positive or negative interval helps you
with one of these other two statements
so let's see it was getting warmer
between 2:00 a.m. and 2:00 p.m. the
temperature was above zero between 8
a.m. and 8 p.m. so see if we're talking
about positive or negative intervals so
we're not talking about increasing or
decreasing we're talking about positive
or negative intervals so we have a
negative interval sorry we have a
negative interval from time equals zero
time equals eight what do I mean by
negative interval is the temperature is
negative it goes it's it's below zero
and then from time from eight hours from
8 a.m. to what is this this would be
noon this would be 8 p.m. from 8 a.m. to
8 p.m. or the 20th hour if you're taking
in military time so to speak we see that
our temperature is positive and then it
go dips down to negative again so a
positive or negative interval tells us
when our temperature was above or below
zero and we can see we have this
positive interval where the temperature
was above zero between 8 a.m. and 8 p.m.
so we're only using the positive
interval this interval right over here
where the function is positive that
means that the temperature was above
zero degrees Celsius between 8 a.m. and
8 p.m. so once again we don't with it's
saying either the positive or the
negative interval helped us make the
statement in this case it was only the
positive interval helped us make this
statement and then finally we have
increasing or decreasing interval and it
was getting warmer between 2 a.m. and 2
p.m. it was getting warmer between 2
a.m. which is right over here
so we see that the function is
increasing as T increases so does the
temperature all the way to 2 p.m. and
that right of there is an increasing
interval so once again we're not using
an increasing and and decreasing it but
we're just using the increasing interval
the decreasing interval isn't helping us
to make the statement but the increasing
interval is I'm helping us letting us
make the statement it was getting warmer
between 2:00 a.m. and 2:00 p.m.
from here to here or between 2:00 a.m.
and 2:00 p.m. we see that the function
itself is increasing that is an
increasing increasing interval and we
got it right